oh god we're i'm already messing this up
great
by the way i'm here for comic relief
that's what i do in cookbook club hi
everybody
we're here with the beautiful on the
inside
and outside haley thomas we are kicking
off cookbook club
which i am so excited to do with her
beautiful book living lively which is
incredibly
incredibly unique as it has these
amazing
questions and journal entries this is
one of the most
personal and interactive books i've ever
come across
and we're going to be making your
islander lively bowl
from it because cookbook club is all
about getting recommendations to
cookbooks and i love food but i'm not a
professional chef
and what i really want to hear is from
amazing foodies so haley take it away
what is your cookbook club
recommendation my recommendation
is the flavor bible it's this huge book
that
basically it's just like a go-to guide
if you're not sure
like what spices to use or what
ingredients to combine
this is a great way to kind of like make
your
your recipe and kind of create something
super fun there are so many
flavors in here so many ingredients and
basically
it's like an encyclopedia you look
through see what ingredient you
want to cook or try and then it's got
all of
the ingredients that pair well with it i
think for people
who maybe can't get to school also
for cooking this is school
this is a this is a culinary institute
book
i feel like i'm studying something you
know like when you're going through it
it really does feel like
like it's teaching you and and you're
able to just create so many new flavor
connections and
yeah it's just such a great kind of
gateway tool to being
more like adventurous with cooking and
food i
feel like i'm just gonna go to it and
reference it
all the time now food is a journey
through so many
moments in our lives it can define so
many things and
like when i think back to my trips or
the things i love favorite family
memories food is always involved so
i feel like it's it's so beyond
necessity
my journey with food also has been like
a complete swinging pendulum i was
always like
dieting and working out and eating super
clean and i was
so happy with the results but i would
have to do it for so long that by
a certain point i would just get
frustrated throw the whole program out
the window and then just
it's so easy to get overwhelmed because
you hear about all these different
things and then
you know there's opposing views and
different diets lifestyles and so
i just feel like finding that happy
balance that place where you can
you know feel good about what you're
putting into your body and also enjoy
all the flavors and the process of it
and to you know understand too that
how we treat our bodies doesn't have to
you know automatically like
connect to our external look you know i
think
a lot of even in plant-based eating a
lot of it started out with like this is
a way to lose weight like super fast you
know
but now the narrative's shifting to like
how can i just make my body feel good
how can i have
sustainable energy throughout the day
and i think reframing it through this
like self-love perspective is
revolutionary and i'm really happy that
we're moving the conversation towards
that and i'm so happy
like you are discovering that as well i
was really drawn to this bowl because
it's genuinely how i eat and a bowl is
an art and it seems a little
intimidating
so take us through this teach us how to
make a beautiful bowl
so making a beautiful bowl should be
that creative and joyful process
and actually for anyone who's like
overwhelmed by how to make a bowl i have
a section called buildable workshops so
it talks all about really what you need
to put together a successful and
delicious
bowl so you've got all the resources you
need in living lively for that but
this islander bowl is one that i love so
much because it reminds me
of flavors i've always you know grown up
having
both of my parents are jamaican so like
island flavors are a big thing in my
house
so what we're gonna do right now is make
the pineapple salsa
and it's just a simple combo of a few
ingredients so we can add it together
so first we'll start off by adding our
diced pineapple
oh god i'm already messing this up great
by the way i'm here for comic relief
that's what i do in cookbook club yes
you're the professional i'm the amateur
pineapple so we're adding our pineapple
to a bowl here
now we're going to add some diced cherry
tomatoes
and these fun fact i actually got to
pick myself at the farm like
right next door to me so really i've got
the seasonal aspect yeah
so making this in summer is great
because we can use more seasonal
ingredients
i think if you get the chance to have
like five minutes in nature it can
change the whole course of your day
yeah seriously it's so rejuvenating and
beautiful when you can interact with
your food like on the vine and then see
it kind of make its way to your kitchen
okay so our tomatoes our pineapples now
we're gonna add some diced onions
we have diced jalapeno i am a
fan of spice but if you're not you know
you can use less
of course but i love it okay
so got all that now we're just gonna add
our cilantro
and finally we're just going to add some
lime juice to kind of moisten everything
and then we'll just mix it all up
so once it's like mostly incorporated we
can add salt and pepper to taste
and i love keeping it really simple with
the seasonings on this one just because
i love the freshness of the pineapple
the tomatoes like i want that to be the
star so
so our salsa is all incorporated on my
end so we can actually get ready to
build this bowl because
that is my favorite part that's really
when the artistry comes out
it's funny you talked about self-love
not something i'm good at i'm like i
don't have time
i i everybody else first but doing
something like this for myself you know
once a week
that is my version of self-love a
vintage floral napkin
a floral bowl and some peach colored
cutlery
exactly like it doesn't have to be
complicated i think we
think of self-love as something that has
to be like a spa trip a face mask a
bubble bath it can literally just be
anything
that brings you joy or replenishes you i
think it's all my self-love
involves cookbooks food cooking
like kitchen stuff it's my heart is in
the kitchen
yes i love it we've got um in a bowl
here we just have some brown rice
you could use quinoa or something i've
been really obsessed with lately that
maybe
you haven't tried yet is an african
super green
ponyo yes
oh my gosh for arbol we've got brown
rice in here
and now what i'm gonna do is just add
kind of all around the bowl
our different components so i'll
actually start with this salsa that we
just made
i just section it out for like the
aesthetic and then when i eat it
everything gets
completely mixed together okay good so
now we're gonna add
our mushrooms and these were marinated
in like
a maple tamari and sesame marinade and
it just
infuses it with such delicious flavors
and
nice sweet smokiness and i love
shiitake mushrooms with like my entire
existence they're so good
love the texture great replacement for
meat but
the marinade really sets it off so then
what i'm gonna do
is add some pickled onions and i love
pickled onions for
the tang like it's just such a fantastic
pop
that it adds to this bowl in particular
but overall i could add pickled onions
to anything
watching a lot of cooking shows which is
also how i've
learned about food and flavors
is they always talk about the balance of
acid yes
so i'm adding my avocado now
right here i did my best too
oh yeah yours just looks better
i think the the point of it is that it
can be a unique expression so
every bowl is beautiful in my eyes final
step is
just putting a dollop of the cilantro
aioli and this
in my opinion is really what brings it
all together the creaminess is just
like unbelievable
[Music]
i am really really excited about
this this is so beautiful and
so healthy and positive the energy you
put into your food
absolutely affects the experience so i
always try to make sure like
i'm in a good state of mind when i'm
cooking and i'm enjoying the whole
process this is
absolutely gorgeous thank you so much
for
bringing this into my life right now and
everybody
who gets to see this really truly thank
you haley
you're so cool thank you thank you so
much for having me and
making one of my favorites from living
lively it's like that's why i called it
the lively islander bowl because i
really feel like it's got that
that flair to it it's fun it's delicious
and
just so soul and body nourishing thank
you haley thank you so much
[Music]
you